the wait for the division is nearly over
and if you want to jump in on the action
as soon as possible you might want to
get your pre-order in right now the
servers will be switched at 1201 am
australian eastern daylight time on
march eight this comes out to march 7th
at five a.m. PST or 8 a.m. EST time to
set those alarms if you plan on playing
the division on xbox one then you can
start pre-loading the game today PC
users will have to wait an extra day
while ps4 players can start downloading
on march six in other news about the
division Xbox one hardware Microsoft is
releasing a four-hundred-dollar system
bundle that comes with a one terabyte
console and a copy of the game
additionally the company is giving away
a special edition black and orange
system to one winner the divisions open
vado recently ended it attracted 6.4
million players across pc ps4 and xbox
one representing a new record for a new
ip's beta on new generation consoles
ubisoft has high hopes for the division
as the publisher recently said it could
join destiny watch dogs and Assassin's
Creed to become one of the biggest new
IP launches ever for more news as we
approach the division's launch and our
thoughts on the game as we're going
through the review process stay tuned to
gamespot com
you